all right well the queens of the couture
donuts are right here in las vegas rocky
is live inside saint honore's newest
castle hey rocky
hey julian and mercedes yes i have to
say castle because these donuts are fit
for royalty okay and yes these are the
queens this is lynn alexandra alexander
you've been on the show before with cafe
lola but now we're talking about saint
honore your couture donut and beignet
shop let's define what couture donuts
means
okay so we actually really wanted to
elevate the donut experience and create
something that no one's ever seen before
so that's what we really consider the
the couture donut we wanted to create
something that no one has ever seen
before and just really elevate that
donut absolutely and they're elevated
and look and taste okay and lynn how
about the aesthetic of this place
because everywhere you guys every shop
you guys open has a different aesthetic
a different look what's the inspiration
for this one yeah we just like to refine
everything that we do so this all
started with our concept the refine
agency which is our marketing company
your experience refined and we like to
do that in our restaurants so saint
honore is the patron saint of all pastry
chefs so we wanted to make the space
super regal very very chic as well as
modern so i think we did a great job
with this space i think you did too and
i have to say you guys did a great job
with the playlist as well you guys can't
hear it but we've got all the heads
bumping in here when you guys walk in
now you guys are opening this you guys
have opened this new location why this
area of the community
well lynn is really in charge of our
that i'm going to change yeah she she's
a great one she was the one that finds
all these great amazing locations all
right tell us why we brought this gym to
blue diamond yeah absolutely you know
the southwest is booming this is blue
diamond is you know
coming up and there's so many
restaurants that are coming to blue
diamond so we thought this was a great
natural progression we have a
drive-through at this location which
we're extremely extremely excited about
which is new for us but we'll do so
really really well so this is a perfect
space we're we're glad to have been
given this space and we just can't wait
to see what we can do with it i love it
okay and now that i have you two
together finally i have to ask you know
what is the key to building a business
together for someone watching out there
who might have a bestie or a partner and
they're thinking of ideas how do they
bring them to life wants to go first
i can i can talk about how um so our
partnership is really unique because we
i have my phd she has her law degree and
um so i'm i'm the i'm the one that kind
of creates all the donuts and she
handles all the growth of our businesses
so if you find someone that really has
you know your weaknesses you become kind
of a powerhouse and you could really
grow much faster
you guys make each other better i love
that okay coming up later in the show we
gotta talk about the donuts the beignets
and also
the secret pizza yeah you gotta stay
tuned for that i'll send it back to you
pizza doughnuts a drive-through my
favorite things all in one i know it's a
one-stop shop i love it thank you so
much rocky